E RUSSIANS ARES THEY
APPROAV?
>> Repr: WELL,Y, IT ISARTOL
A
ALONE IN A TINY VILLAGE LIKE
IS.EA
MILES, T
VILLAGE THAT HAS NO REAL
AIR ST O, IT WAS SUBJECT OF A F
JUST TAKE  AT THIS.
HOUSESD THIS
THAT RUSSIAN AIR STRIKE.E LOOK
MAN NAMED IGORHO WE SPOKE WI
EARLIEE IS A HE CRATER HERE IN
THE
HE LOST FI O
MEMBERELL AS A FRIEND.
WI WIFE'
S MOTHER-I IA
CAR WHEN THETRIK.
KILLED.
HEWHHE WAS ALSO
HE SAID OBVIOUSLY  HE IS
JUST EMPTY
S HORRIFIE WHAT'S GOIN
HE DOESN'T KNOWWHATIS.
SO TS DESTRU
GE AT GOES TO ABBY, THIS IG
ALL ACROSSS COUNTRY.
AND CLOSETO YIV.
OW THEORERAT TE
THE WEST IN THEIR EFFORTS TO
LE IT ANTOE
CITY AND T IT OF
WE'VE BEEN ASE
ON THALUT HAING CLOSER TKYIV, BW
STANDSTILL, BUT, ABB
NOW IS BECAUSE OF
PRSSNS HAVE
MADE O
THAT FE YASTIT UP IN THE SKIESAE
E THISONLY OTH
GENERALN O IN, T
CIVILIT PEOPLEO
SU, E TO LEAVE. CONTINUES TO
SAY THAT THEY ARE NOT TARGETIN
CIT STRING CIVIAN
KE YOUNATE THESE AKS ARE
W BADLUKRAN S ARE SUFFERAB, ALE
D WHAT DOEELE INTE THE ATTACKS H
OFYIV?
>> Reporter: IT SAYS TWOT'S
COMPTEE DON'T KNOW
TOT THEY ARE ING
DINATE.
AFTER MILITARYCTURE.ID
THIS HOME HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE MILITARY.
ITHIN MILES
THAT HAS ANYTHING TO DO
MILITA.SO THA THE QUESTION, ARE
THE RUSSIAY BA
AIMING?
IS THAE KILL F
ALL THESE RESIS OR
IT LOOKSD MOREY BE THE CASE.SIL
HE RSI
THO ALLOPE
NITARI
CORRIDORS, BUT  BOMBING NF NEARR
TRYING TO GET RE PEOPL
HAVE BEE
SO IES CERTAINLYPP
ETS ARE OFF.
THAT CERTAINLY WE OTSIANS ARE S
INTENTIONS HER CLEARLY NOT JUST
TEE MILI
CIVILIANS AS WEL ABBY. YR EXCE
ALEMAUA THERE.OWTID
ENN,
FORMER CNDE U.S.
NATO FORCEL ALLEN, WHAT ALEX JU
DE WE HAVE -- ERE HE IODAY IS
INS SORT OF SOUTHWESTERN
IDLSO, AS WE JUST MENTIONED,
NG
HEOF THE CITY.
WE KNO BEEGH
RE DOING?
THEY HAVE STRUGGLED TO TAK.
ARE DOING WITH BRAVE REPTERS
ONO 'S RHETORICAL  EIS THE
RE THEY BAD AT OR  WAR ON THE U.
IT'S BOTH.
WE'VDI
RUSSIAN MILITARYCAPABLE THAN WER
ENCIRCLEME OF KYIV THEY'VE NOW
LENG TEAK DOWN
THE AT THE.
IT ABOUT KYIVMADE IT DIFFICULT
RUSSIAN TOSS ADVANCE.
THEY ARE COMING  FH ANATTACKING.
ELSE??IS IOR
BOTH. MILITARY IS ROAD
THAT HASATEDH N THE ROADLOGISTIR
COLUMNS HAOOD N .E YAN MILITA U
H L AXISOWARDS
THE RUSSIAN ADVANCE IN THE  COU
FOHE UKRAIT THE RUSSIAN N THEIAN
UNRAVEE THINGS MENT WOULD
AND WITMAAPABLE
ESOR TIAN FL
OF TO ACCOMPLISH TIR CITIES IN
ANRTS OF THE EASHAVE
ALREADY EXPERICED THAT
JU TO SHOW AUDIENCE RE
WE INTENSE FIGHTINKHERSOARIUPOI.
YOU'VE AR OUR INTRO TO
THIS BLOTHEY ARE T
ABOUT A LACK OF  OF WAK OFICITY
>> THE ANSWER TO YOUQUISE ARE W
BA LONG
E TO INDICTMENT AS A F  MMITTED
IT'S NOT JUST THE POWER,
IS T HUMANY THAT
BEING INFLICTED ON THESEPOPULATE
LI.
COMING OUT OF TH WAS ONER KHARK
CONTROL THE SOUTHERN COAST OF
UKRAINE ALONBLACK SEA AND A OFSS
RESTY ARE GOING FOR ES
NEXT.
>> I THERE IA ON
MOLDOVA POTENTIALLY CREATING AN.
ENSKYY THE
COMING F ODESA.
WHAT IS THE SIGNIFICANCE OF ATCR
D OF COURSE IT IE LAE FALL OF OL